Hey, what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on. You
see now your week's going. I
know your week's going great.
And Philly right now. She'd not a sports
fan then. You probably all upset it.
Everybody's all excited running around,
tearing up the streets sides,
you know,
eating horse shit.
I felt bad for that Philly fan that had
to eat horse shit. You know what I mean?
It's just all the shit that
diff fans have gotten, you know,
attention for like the bar has just been
set so high that this poor bastard that
was through, he was like
out of ideas, you know,
you know where it is as far
as bad behavior, you know,
or Philly fans are right now.
It's kind of like,
remember when they did the dunking contest
every year in the all star game and
at first it was amazing, you know, so we'd
just like takes off from the foul line.
It's like, Holy Shit. You
know, the next thing you know,
you've got to have like some fucking
quivering fucking woman standing there and
you got to jump and your balls have to
just scrape the top of her fucking head
while you covered your eyes
like Dee Brown. You know,
that's kind of like where
eagles fans had flyers, fans.
All Philly fans are as far as like,
how the fuck are we going to get on
ESPN this time? What are we going to do?
Throw up on a kid already did that.
What are we going to do?
Punch an old lady in the con.
Ah,
we've been doing that since
the 70s what does fall, my God,
there's a pile of horse shit.
Ah,
turn on your fucking video camera.
That didn't even make sense.
I'm not going to put that on eagles fans.
I'm not going to put that on Philly.
I'm in bed is an individual act.
That guy wanted to do that
shit for the longest time.
He just needed an excuse.
You know what I mean?
It's like all of us, most of us have
never eaten another human being. Right.
But put in the right situation,
you'd fucking do it. Right.
What was that movie alive plane
crashes in the rocky mountains.
You know, they're right next
to aspen, but they're all rich,
so they're not going to help out.
It wouldn't give them a sandwich.
And next thing you know,
they're eating each other.
There's this have to do with Eaton.
Why the fuck did this have
to do with eating horse shit?
I was trying to think where they
actually landed. Where was it?
They didn't land the crashed.
I would actually be upset if I survived
that. You know, like you're like,
Oh fuck, I'm gonna die. Right.
And then you fucking survive me on top
of that mountain freeze and you fucking
ass off then you wish you did.
Um,
anyways. Anyways, um,
I actually was finally able to look at
some of the highlights because I really
wanted to see eagles fans celebrating.
I just couldn't handle it cause
they'd beat my team. And, um,
I believe I said,
you know,
on the podcasts and towards the end of
December that if the Patriots get bounced
out of the playoffs, I was going
to root for the fucking eagles,
just cause you know, they
had one, one, like I said,
I really don't have
anything I wanted to say.
I forgot to say that on Conan because
so many people fucking reached out,
you know,
Twitter and all of this crap because of
my Philly rent thinking I really didn't
want the eagles to ever win one. And all
of it. It's just I got booed in Philly.
I made fun of Philly.
If I got booed in Texas,
I would have made fun of pickup trucks
and women who wear too much makeup.
You know, when you dumb fucking
boots walking around. All right,
if you've got a flat screen TV and
not a fucking cowboy, all right.
You look like you're on
your way to a gay bar.
I would've said something like that in
Texas. That's what I would've done. Oh,
look who's here.
They'll love bleed knee.
The fuck are you eating?
What are those things called?
Panoramas alright, take it
down. Take it down a bit. Hey,
that's when you know your wife's here.
Hey, what are you having a good time?
Take it down a bit. I'm eating pomegranate
seeds. I'm eating pomegranate seeds.
I heard they're good for my
ovaries and my lady parts. They do.
I heard, I read that this post to shine
up the advantage lips over there. Oh baby.
You know it's weird. Has
a weird segue, you know,
a year ago or so when I didn't have a kid,
oh,
we'll go back a year and a half when you
didn't get yourself knocked up. Right.
Um, I would just be walking around the
house that would be singing whatever
contemporary shit that you know,
you would listen to to, you know,
did she say why gold and Michelle
fiber that some bum, right.
I'd been singing that shit. Right. Okay.
Then now that we have a kid down
there brushing my teeth going right,
whoa.
Bab Arena.
I may be blue with Koi tea tea's Whoa,
arena,
but I'm not so different in Daddy.
Yeah. What happened? What happened to me?
A pop up a puppy dog
close when they're going through,
when they go on the adventure.
How's the song go? Go in on a
mission, not a mission that's
going on. A mission going on
a mission. That's true. Sure
about. Ooh, what? Oh, I was,
that's why I brought you on.
Yeah. Yeah. Those are me undies
beyond these sent matching,
matching. Underwears I love
it. They're so cute. What's,
what's on this a Taco with hot sauce.
You get it.
Do you need to be explained that
hearing these on Valentine's Day,
I may make him be fun in front of me
for being a redhead. I didn't make it.
Make it fun. Make it be fun of me
for being a redhead. What though?
What the hot sauce did you see the text
that I sent you that now they're going
to have red hand emojis in June? Uh, yeah.
Which I just think it's going
to lead to more redheaded hate.
The thing about being a redhead is what
you want to do is not stand next to
another red head. You want to sort
of like fade into the background.
But you know what, you don't really,
you're not going to use those.
But they also have, um, bald, bald
emojis. Do they have a bald what?
The Red Beard?
I don't know if the baldy has facial hair.
When am I ever going to
fit in my whole life? Oh,
when are you ever be represented?
No.
You realize how difficult it is
to be a redheaded white male.
He's so close to the brass ring,
but those blue blood and what?
They won't let me get to know Jesus.
I am like the lazy,
I'm like the runt of the litter. The
one that the mother rejects. Yeah.
You're the real underdog. Um,
I hate when you do you? Yeah,
you're the real law under the, why
don't you just do it in a giant fucking,
I roll with that.
There it is a meme level.
It looks beautiful outside. So why
don't you put on your underwear, Nini?
I want to see you in those.
I want to wear it on Valentine's Day.
We have to both where I'm Valentine's Day.
No we don't.
That's why they get cause.
I'm going to,
I'm an adult and I can make my own
choices despite the fact that you know
something. What's killing me? Can
you just wear your taco underwear?
Can you just have a little
fun and not be so uptight?
Did you just say uptight like we're in
a fucking black and white comedy movie
here. He's white and she's black.
She teaches up to loosen up. Huh?
You're really uptight. You're not
uptight. I'm a fucking control freak.
I don't like people telling me what to do.
It means you're uptight.
If you're a control freak,
that means you're uptight.
No, it doesn't. Yeah, it does.
Oh, black people uptight because a sick
of white people fucking running shit.
What does that have to do with anything
that troll did Janet Jackson do a whole
fucking album about that?
Why am I here? Because I want you
to see the match and underwear.
I thought you'd have fun with
it rather than put demands on.
Isn't it enough that I have
to pay for the whole evening?
We're celebrating our relationship.
Where is your contribution?
Oh yeah,
but you supposed to do that.
You supposed to do that. They blowy. Yeah,
but you're supposed to want to do that.
That's the question. No money.
And you're burning calories.
Ridiculous burning
calories. What do you, what?
It's an aerobic exercise
if done correctly. Oh,
whoa.
Getting a blow.
We were wearing matching underwear.
Don't fuse those two worlds
together. I will. And I just did.
MMM. It's because of that world
that you now have a new world.
Okay. There you go. Okay. By
the way, I, I lovely little one.
Um, oh, she uh, she took her first
steps this week. Oh, it was awesome.
I want to start crying. Yeah, she did.
It's funny. You're going to start crying.
I wanted to film it and then fucking
put Aerosmith's walk this way.
Underneath it. Yeah. Be
Time she falls, that debt
ball get, and we'll hit the snare as
when she falls down and arrest. So cute.
She was so proud of herself too.
I didn't realize babies get like
proud of themselves. Yeah. Like what?
She learns how to do stuff. She looks over
and smells like, Huh? Yeah. Look at me.
Seeing this. He checking
this out. So cute. Um,
anyway, so, well, let's get down
to what everybody's talking about.
The scandalous interview
by a Quincy Jones. Nia. Ah,
Jesus Christ. Iconic and Rbo. I
didn't like it. Of course she's in.
What do you like bill? What a was
popular that you actually enjoy?
What do you mean? There's a bunch of shit
that I like. Chocolate cupcakes. Oh look,
a basket full of puppies. I hate it.
Like what's not? No, that's true.
I like cupcakes.
I actually know how to make them and
I've made you some and I love dogs.
You've never made me a cupcake. You
fucking whore. Put that microphone. Yeah,
that's exactly what I just said.
Excuse me. There's no need for that.
I drove all over the fucking La base and
trying to find you a fucking Yellow Cup
cake with chocolate frosting and it
didn't exist and I went out and I fucking
made them for you.
You don't remember that.
You haven't that were in
your life made me cupcakes.
And this is in Los Angeles or in New
York? This is here. Like when the last,
within the last two years.
Give me that microphone off the podcast.
You're up the podcast.
I don't remember that.
Unbelievable.
You made it and you went out and bought
me cupcakes like late at night when I'd
have like cupcake cravings.
But you've never made because that
would mean you'd make it like a dozen
cupcakes because that's how
many were in the pants. Yeah.
And you frosted them and everything.
Yeah. I don't remember this.
Okay.
I ain't fucking with me, right? No.
Go into the cupboard and go look.
There's a fucking cupcake tray.
Why would I have one of those?
Uh, that's right. There it is guys.
For years,
the only as good is the last act.
It doesn't mean shit to them.
You know the Patriots are always
just pushing fucking all pros out.
The door liners are in there too.
Yeah, yeah, that's right. Yeah. Wow.
Well guess who's not
making cupcakes anymore?
Maybe I should film it. Well, you make
some for Valentine's Day. No. Why? Why?
Cause you're not going to remember.
And then you can come on a podcast.
You know what?
I made red velvet ones and meanwhile
I'm wearing matching underwear.
I'm playing the game, I'm playing the
game, right. And then I make it cupcakes.
You don't even remember. How dare
you. You look gorgeous. So by the way,
oh name, he's been hitting the
gym and I've been noticing,
I'm trying to keep it together,
keep it together, keep it together.
Do you know my issue is positive
right there. I made you cupcakes.
I said you're looking good. All of that.
Whose wedding? Like about Quincy Jones,
he was talking shit about
people who were dead.
And then everybody took
everything he said is fact.
And it's like you didn't notice
halfway his gold. I know who killed
Kennedy. Oh Shit. You should
have told Oliver Stone.
He wouldn't have wasted all that time
making that movie when he could have just
called you up. Um, I
just like when he said,
when you go for the money,
God walks out the room.
That's where like as far as
all that gossip about everybody
else, it's like, dude,
why once you grow up?
Huh?
Okay,
well who? Who goes around doing that?
Who just got used to steal songs.
He didn't say that. When you will
make an records with the whip,
he was still fucking alive.
Tell all the stories. This
is what I'm telling you. You
are mad. Cool, cool. Damn it.
Old People, my family, they
just, they don't give a fuck.
They're just tell him
stories about everybody.
This person did this and this person
did this and back in the day it was that
because what are they apt to
lose? They're not, you know,
fearful of being politically correct.
Let me get this straight line.
You're not supposed to be.
Yes, you supposed shit.
You're not supposed to be a snitch.
He's supposed to keep your mouth shut
and all of that shit your whole fucking
life. He's not in the end when everybody,
do you know what the fuck? I mean,
well,
I dunno how I was brought up.
What'd she didn't do that to
people? It does get stitches. No,
not that street shit. Yeah. Like I
said, I don't pop off. I'd flip out,
but even in the hard
streets in the suburbs,
pretty classic line I
think for the podcast.
But I lived in that Culdesac you want
to talk about dead end streets, man,
you had to go out my suburb
but street ended and all it was was
beautiful woods into a lovely pond
lunch yesterday with mom and she like,
did you hear her?
Like kind of chastised
me for not drinking water
cause it all,
but I wish I could have enjoyed that.
Claudia and I drank a whole bunch of
water like the whole entire morning and
then automatically they automatically
filled up my glass again for more.
All right. In Password. They
just automatically filled
it up and my mom was like,
do you want some water? And
I was like, no, it's okay.
And she like hits me on the arm
just you should be drinking water.
And it's like I drink
water all God damn day La.
It was just a mother's love I guess.
So I just annoyed me anyway.
It has nothing to do a little word. Hey
Nia, you should drink more water. Wow.
I literally drink water all day long.
Nobody notices that system and why
in that moment she had to like,
I dunno. It literally has been bothering
me since yesterday so it doesn't, yeah,
hold on.
I wouldn't have slapped you on the wrist
if I knew it was really bothering you.
It's just annoying. You want to talk
about it, Neil? No, I got it off my chest.
That's what I've learned about women.
You just, Oh, I didn't know that.
You just said about women. No,
nothing. You have no instincts.
You have no intuition.
I nailed that whole thing about how you
guys stopped giving compliments when you
get married and you even said,
fair enough. I don't remember that.
Of course you don't just like the
cupcakes. You know what's funny?
I'm going to stop doing shit for you.
Just say that I did it.
Cause you're not going to remember either
way and you're going to be like, wow,
I must, I can't believe I keep forgetting
that I have the greatest husband ever.
He made me a chocolate
cupcakes. I'll keep, forget
what I, I can't believe that fucking
sat to what? That God damn kitchen aid.
I weren't goddamn apron foil. What do I
get for that? Huh? Nuh Huh? I'm sorry.
I can't remember. Oh, look at you. A
little sunflower icon. Isn't that cute?
I've never noticed that.
I think that comes with it.
So what's up? What's up? Why am I here?
Because I want you to see the
underwear and I want you to, you know,
thank you. Me, Andy's, there you go.
And that's, that's the uh, that's,
that's the one advertiser we
have today. Oh, great photo.
Boop, boop. Me. Andy's me.
Andy's match and fucking Hondo.
Where's Doo Doo Doo Doo Mija.
Andy's me ideas.
Put them on.
If you don't cares if fuck kid trapped
in your relationship or the food,
she don't give a shit. She's not going
to remember if you made a cupcakes.
So just fucking tell her that she had
did cause you're a loser. All right?
You want to to look,
you want to look good knee up with your
significant others this Valentine's Day,
rather
than check out me undies matching pairs.
I should have been trashed in these, oh,
I can't wait to wear these batch and
underwear with you. A unique, fun gift.
But yeah. Yeah. Your Valentine.
They're the perfect balance of
comfortable fit and exciting prince.
Uh, don't spend another Valentine's
Day giving the same old gift.
Checkout me undies Dotcom and find
the best match for your match.
Did you see how suddenly there was
saying that I was a redhead with the hot
sauce representing the Dick? No, you
didn't. I thought you'd find that funny.
Talk about why me undies matching pairs
of the best Valentine's gift ever. Uh,
feel free to improvise reservoir. These
are so cute. I can't even tell you.
Put them on the very thoughts right now.
Put Him on right now.
I want to see what you look like.
All right,
me undies are the most comfortable and
fun undies that you're going to wear.
Geezes uh,
me are the most comfortable and fun on
whether, do you ever gonna wear the,
and these are the most comfortable
underwear that you ever to,
I'm not looking at the coffee.
God dammit.
You fill out a fucking pair on
say are any of you go over there and
I'll pick up something that I uh,
forgot William. Um, all right.
You know what? Just for that I am going
to where the other parent, God dammit Nia.
Alright me undies are the most
comfortable this last time,
the most comfortable and fun on these
you and your significant other will ever
own. They're made from the softest
materials on earth, wind and fire.
Oh yeah, I did it. Feel good up here.
Up against you who we're talking
three times softer than cotton.
Soft this Valentine's Day.
Get Your partner at gift.
That's for the both of you.
Order by February 5th at 10:00
AM for free standard shipping.
So your gift arise in time.
100% satisfaction.
Guarantee me undies guarantees you and
your significant other will love your
matching pairs or your money back.
That's the first time anybody's got
naked on the podcast. Right now. Me.
Andy's has an exclusive Valentine's
Day offer that just from my listeners,
for any first time purchases when you
purchased me undies, matching pairs,
you get 20% off and free shipping.
Me undies is so sure you'll love
their underwear, their off offer.
They offer a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair,
you'll get a full refund. Uh,
what are you waiting for?
Order by February 5th for free.
Standard Shipping need to get 20% off
your matching pairs. Free Shipping.
100% satisfaction guarantee. Well,
that part's over right. Go to uh,
well at least the February 5th thing.
Um, [inaudible] dot com slash bird,
that's meundies.com/bird does.
This will be the best Valentine's
Day gift that you will ever give.
Start matching your bottom
half to your better half.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar
right now. That's cute. It's very clever.
Her wrote down. It is your bottom half
to your better half. There you go.
Our anniversary's coming up. Yeah, and we
don't even officially know the date. No,
we don't. No, we don't.
I mean,
do we always say it's Valentine's Day?
No, we don't. And we never go
out on Valentine's Day. No.
We usually go out a couple of days after
when the price has come back to some
sort of sensible, you know, you
can get a table, right? Bounce.
I say you go to Wendy's at
night, they're like, we're sorry.
It's going to be like a 45 minute wait.
But we never came up with like,
I guess we just now our anniversary is
our wedding date as opposed to like the
first time we ever hung out. Right? Yeah.
Neither one of us are big on dates. No,
but in one of us is a
little bigger on cupcakes,
but it was February 14
years ago. Wow. Yup.
That's so crazy.
14 years
still looking.
You still looking great.
Now they'll tell you that and I already
knew that until that little little
fucking display you just put on.
I'll make you cupcakes.
I knew each other and you look good
too. All right, let's stop this.
This is annoying people.
All right. Thank you.
The Conan O'brien show
for get me on on Monday.
Even though much of it was
painful for me to sit there.
I think a Philly fans deserve that.
You know,
after all this shit they've
got because of that rant,
which I said once again was not fun.
It wasn't personal. It was a personal,
it just so long ago too.
It was,
that's the funny thing is now people
that go to another you share you get was,
well, he fucking won one and only took
half a century fucker. You bragging about.
That's like the guy who fucking finishes
a marathon in Lynn, like nine hours.
It's like,
yeah dude, I could have walked it
and that, that amount of time. Also,
that audience deserves it. Who did
the audience and Villi they deserve?
Yeah, they did. They were
assholes. Yeah, and it was funny.
Most of them probably have kids now and
they're raising little asshole kids,
but you know something. Not
all Philly fans. I like that.
I remembered having Shay's a nice
guy. Oh we love you. You know you,
I remember those guys aren't always
sunny. Yeah, they're nice guys.
I didn't see them do it. Yeah. They
weren't tipping over any cars and stuff.
Oh my God.
Um,
I remember you called me after that
whole thing in Philly happen and you were
like, I have a massive headache.
And I said, what happened? He like,
I just got into a fight
with like 10,000 feet.
You did you call me right
after it happened. I'll never
forget it. And I was like,
oh my God. Whoa. And then
it just blew up. And I think
that's right.
You were at my apartment that I was when
I rode home with Bobby Kelly and he's
going to judge Whitehead tonight.
Kid. Yeah. I was like, Bobby,
I've got a headache. Yeah. Does
people, they go back and shells get,
you know what Bobby Kelly
had to follow that night?
Bobby Kelly had to go on after
the intermission where they,
somebody was an ear infection.
Drained it. Somebody else drank it.
And somebody who watched it.
Cute.
This is in Philly?
Yeah.
What is going on with the P and
let that guy that he'd horse shit.
Like what is going on? No, no,
no, no. Well, what is going
on over there? Seriously.
You know what happened to Philly was
when they built night interstate 95 they,
they got bypassed.
Okay.
So I just think that
they're just stuck in time
back in a time when people ate horse
shit. I don't know. I don't know why.
I think there's something there.
There's either some sacred burial
ground that they built the city on,
or there's some sort of toxic waste,
like the Simpsons thing going on.
I don't know what their deal is,
but all I know is they don't care that
people don't like them and they're proud
of their behaviors.
So I say God bless him.
There's some really amazing people
though, and affiliate. Right?
If you had the Horse Shit, uh, the roots,
that's not a person, Jill
Scott. It's a band. Um,
all the black people
I know. You're like really racist,
Huh? Kevin Hart. Keith Robinson.
Kevin Hart. Yeah. I didn't
know that he sold out the Eagle
Stadium. Yeah. And he was,
he did stand up in a fucking football.
So funny. He was so happy after they won.
You saw him on TV drunk. So I can,
but I know that sounded hilarious,
so it was pretty great. It was pretty
great. He was very happy. Yeah.
So that's the deal. I'm, what
am I going to get mad? You know,
my team can't win it every
year. Right, right. I know.
I think you're very gracious about it.
You like,
that's the one thing you've actually
mellowed out about as the years have gone
by. I mean, I can't, it
compliments, go ahead boards.
That's the one thing I can actually say.
I see you
improvement on the rest of it is
taking a fucking nose dive now.
You're very gracious when it
comes other teams. Yeah. I don't,
I don't take it to the point of like,
like I said, I just, you know, what's his,
I retweeted that, that uh,
nick foals audio in the, uh,
in, in the huddle was great. Other than
he said, I love you guys. And just like,
why does everything have
to be so fucking sweet now
I would love to tell a boy,
nick,
I would advise your responses
in a huddle in an NFL game.
I mean,
I would've loved to have had teleported
him back to that fucking 1980 Superbowl
team when they were playing the Raiders
and just be okay before we do this first
place. When to say, I love you guys. I
just said, well, we'll put Montgomery,
look at him when they win the Superbowl
and stop. He can't say, I love you too.
Now when I was not,
when I was a kid,
didn't,
they didn't think anybody.
Actually the cra had emotions when you
were a kid and then all of a sudden it's
a new millennial thing to
have emotion and express them.
Men did not cry when I
was a kid that I saw,
I saw the Celtics went three
championships. I saw the Lakers went five.
I saw the Pistons went to,
you know,
the first time I think I
saw a guide cry was Jordan.
It was because his dad died and he
wasn't there and that was understandable.
You know what I mean?
But he didn't just cry because he won.
He said that angry look on his face going
like five fucking six and you always
seem to win it on the road.
And you know,
he's looking at some little kid
who was crying. He got off on it,
he got off on PNB. That's what
a man was back then. Okay.
Um, first of all, just want
to say, I love you guys
want to just take time to just,
everybody knows how much
weight to offensive line is
lost. You guys, you know,
you were really,
you know,
I dare you coming out of your football
pants the beginning of the year and now
just looking so shapely,
dare you and your next show.
What's the show when you say goodnight?
I dare you to say I love you guys.
Goodnight. I dare you to
say it. Oh, you kidding me?
I would fucking do that per 10 minutes
until everybody just got so on,
so uncomfortable
and left. I want you to
do it shows over. But uh,
I just want to take some time. You'd
just speak from the heart. You know,
my life has changed a lot in the
last year and in a great way.
I became a father and I look at the
world at different time, different way,
and I've noticed the whole thing.
You can just be like, all right, no,
it has to be a big thing because then
they're going to expect that there's going
to be this punchline that never comes.
Right.
And this is going on and on about
how much love you have in your heart.
And don't forget to look at this.
Don't forget to look at the sky today,
everybody, you know, it's those little
things that we take for granted.
If you get some of that fucking
pomegranate and my jacket. Oh, all right.
He was in my jacket is a table.
Yeah. I'm telling you now.
The second this podcast
is over,
we're going to do a dry run.
It puts you a little fucking booty
shorts on just to make sure we're,
as we're in sync.
Oh,
was that was in another life.
I was a the new kids. Yeah.
I'm going to said the right boys.
I can I keep this?
Darryl's. Oh, Joseph Maton sign away.
The rights stuff. You got the
red stuff. That's right babe.
Okay, well I think that
might be where you turn me.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I didn't mean to keep going.
Yeah, but you were of that age, those
boy bands, they caught you, right?
Miss Dead Telephoto. Yes. New Edition.
And then you know the white new edition
also known as new kids on the block.
And wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Are you talking about the
Osmonds came before new edition?
No new edition. Had the same manager.
Okay.
As new kids on the block and their
manager at Maurice Starr said he wanted to
make a white pop crossover version
of new edition that don't get mad,
don't get mad at white people.
It was a black guy's ideas who said,
I'm mad at white people. And you
were doing that fucking Elvis Shit.
New Kids on the block have always given
props and respect to new edition their
whole entire careers.
That's good because I would hate to
know that those two bands are fighting.
Okay.
I'm just saying it's, it's a nice thing.
All right, well you have a new addition.
Got Screwed. They really,
really did big time,
so it's just nice that new kids on
the block has always given them their,
their props.
Okay.
Okay. Why? Why get all weird?
Not Weird. It feels weird.
Well, that's because you live in a
place of fucking awkwardness and anger.
Can I ask you a question? Do you
know what to tell you about my issue?
Question sincerely.
Is it ever you,
is it always me and my world of
awkwardness and anger and negativity,
as you say, fucking unbelievable. If
you guys, of course she said to me,
I woke up this morning,
but I do what I do.
I fucking change my daughter's diaper.
Right?
Okay.
The hanging out with her,
I'm watching cartoons.
It's all the great shit that had
done today and this is what we, all,
she all she talks about how
she just just dials into is my,
is my fucking anger.
Right.
And I haven't even been lost my shit yet
today except when it burned my hand in
the kitchen, which is not why
I yelled. Fuck. That was why?
Because I was putting the fucking
Keno into my thermos and you know,
and it always falls down in between.
That's a stupid harness.
And you said that's why you
screaming obscenity? Yeah,
cause I went out before it fell off the
spoon and went all the way down anyway
to clean it up and I just went fuck. And
you were in the other room, you're like,
whoa.
I was like a burned my hand.
No, you're a sweetheart because you've
just given me a bunch of compliments and I
love you and you're fantastic. Yeah.
That's really, doesn't hold any water.
Been trashing me. But you've been the
last three times were on the podcast.
You make it sound like you're emotionally
held captive here when you're running
the deal. Yeah. Puts into that laugh.
That is the laugh of somebody that's
running a fucking relationship. All right.
That's the podcast for this
week is a very happy anniversary
anniversary. Uh, sit today.
Just be our anniversary.
All right. Why can't we just say the
seventh? I'll remember that. Well,
what day is today? Well, it's the eighth.
So it was yesterday.
What kind of life are you leading that
you don't even know what fucking Datas.
We have the nerve to talk about me. What
month is it? Quick, quick. There you go.
Show a history monster and you'd be
like lighting a candle every day.
Don't they make a giant Black Menorah with
28 candles and science Blackman. Nora.
Yeah, no, I know. Then our,
this day in 1932 I'm reading stories a
little every day about African Americans
and Americans and that did the shill lace,
which was later taken credit was taken
by the light bed and actually it was
three women who were good
at math of African descent.
February 9th
the first steam ship was actually built
by a native American African Blood
Robert Fault and killed that person
that said, I invented the steam ship.
This happened February 9th,
1845.
I said it.
February 9th,
eight eight Oh four Thomas
Jefferson finally gave into
his desires and hopefully
it was her desire to, but that's not
how it worked back then. Yeah. Yeah.
Where are you performing next?
Um,
and the Patrice O'Neal benefit
or Patrice O'Neal benefits.
This is a 54 tickets left.
Uh, something like that. Um,
that's on February 20th. My next
one is going to be in Santa Barbara,
Santa Barbara,
which was actually an African American
named it and 1970 til like people took it
over because they liked the
view of the beach. Are you a,
are you flying to Santa Barbara
and me decided, yes I am.
I'm frying playing a helio copter
out there. Are you chilled? Yo,
meet there and then flying back.
So can I come?
There's no room for you.
What do you mean there's no room?
There's no wrong blue and the
copilot and the opener. Yeah. Okay.
Well I guess that's that then.
Oh two openers to open up.
The still flying out there.
One them is as he,
and I'm going to be fucking dying laughing
cause he hates to fly and it's going
to freak them out that I'm on controls.
Even though we're going
to have the copilot there,
he's going to be freaking tell
whoever the other person is.
It's coming with you to film him. Oh
yeah. When we first go into a habit,
because you know when the
first time you go into Howard,
this one of the weirdest feelings ever,
other than realizing that you
were attracted to me 15 years ago,
14 years ago, it must have
been, am I attracted to that
orange headed Weirdo? Um,
so negative. Well, that's
nice. Nice. That's a nice dog.
And You wonder why I live in a world
of anger and awkwardness. No, no. The,
when I first saw you,
the first time ever,
I saw your freckles really
handsome and I was like,
oh, what were you like? That's,
that's what I always know,
like five years later.
So it was meant to be, oh,
you like me. I saw, I met,
I met my wife in an alley behind the
first one in an alley behind the Apollo.
Yeah, that's the first I
was going into do fish area.
It was going in to do showtime at
the Apollo. My Dad had booked you on,
it's showtime at the Apollo.
My Dad used to book the Comedians on it,
show Timothy Paulo. My Dad is actually
known bill longer than I have. And, um,
I saw, he was like, oh,
I got this funny wipe away from Boston
on the show. And I was like, okay,
cool.
I had just graduated from college and I
went back there and you said hi briefly.
And I was like, oh, he's
really good looking.
And then when I saw you years later on,
tough crowd,
I immediately recognize
you. I was like, oh my God,
that's the guy that I met at
the Apollo with my dad, Jen.
And you were such a jerk to me. I
wasn't, I kept trying to ask you,
he was such an asshole. No,
that's not how it went at all.
I wouldn't even look at me if you were
in the elevator. I was looking over it.
I was like,
think of something to say something
with something saying he was staring
straight ahead like those fucking guys
in London with the big furry hats.
Expressionless trying to play hard to get,
but you also had a girlfriend at the
time and I had a boyfriend. No, I didn't.
Yeah, you did. I thought
I did. No, you did.
And then when we ran into each other
at the party for Chappelle show,
that's when you told me you
didn't have a girlfriend,
but when we first met you did
have it in fucking asked you why?
When I had a girlfriend I know.
Well then all right then and I'll buy,
but you were still looking
at so what I can look,
I was looking to,
even though I had a boyfriend,
but we didn't do anything until after
we were both still after. Exactly. Yeah.
Jesus. That's all you're going to go
all Quincy Jones there. Oh listen.
When you guy kicked the bucket and kicked
the plug that you wait til the week.
I would never do that to you, but I
do. I don't. Why would I give a shit?
I be dead. I had to imagine myself.
No, I don't want to, first of all,
I don't ever want to think about your
time before me. That would be too much.
Well, it's going to happen. I'm 10
years older than you and I'm a guy,
but I do take better care of myself.
Then you do. Wait, what I do,
I do the elliptical.
I swear to God you eat Kina war for
three weeks and you think you're some
fucking like health,
like you really need to knock it off.
Fair enough. You're like, Oh
wow, you don't want to have
so much energy. Yes bill,
we are all aware of like the health
benefits of joining or jealous of my new
healthy diet.
I'm not jealous you are you always nosing
around like a little fucking rabbit.
We didn't know was wiggling like wait,
what are you eating over there?
What are you going over there?
I'm just curious what you're
doing. Cause Yeah, you're,
you're doing really well with your diet
and stuff but I just think be like we're
the first person that discovered Keana
was the way you go on and on about and
not what I think.
What do you think?
I think I went to the dentist yesterday
and found out that I was supposed to do
16 weeks of Invisalign,
but because I've left these things in
sometimes even during shows spitting on
the front too. Fucking rose cause
I want to get this over with.
He says it's only going to be 13 weeks,
and I just put in train number nine,
bitch,
I got another month to
these fucking things.
That's it.
Yeah.
You just, you know, excited. I was,
when I got, you remember when I got,
I remember my, I got your teeth fixed.
All this shit that I've done for you.
Please put it that way.
All this shit that I've done,
I see one more fucking piece of clothing
that you just had to have the chief
judge just frisbee down at a fucking
goodwill for some homeless guy to traipse
around in while these looking
to get his fucking junk.
All right.
I got to get off.
I have to get on on with my fucking day.
This has been the podcast.
We're gonna not play a little bit of music
and then you get to listen to another
half hour of bullshit from a Thursday
podcast, uh, earlier this year,
10 years ago. I don't know how it
works. Um, that's it. All right.
Have a wonderful weekend. You'd concert
once again. Congratulations to everybody.
You'd Philly, uh, please don't eat
excrement from an animal, right?
Eh?
Yeah.
Okay. Hey, what's
going on? It's bill bird and it
is the Monday morning for Monday,
February 8th,
2010 one day after Superbowl 44.
Well, um, usually I don't begin
my podcast with a warning,
but I'm going to this week. Um, if
you live anywhere near Indianapolis,
you want to shut this thing off right now.
Okay?
If you one of those fantasy football
playing Douche bags with your stats and
your Peyton manning poster
hanging above your fucking bed,
you want to shut this thing off right now.
All right?
Because this podcast is
dedicated to you guys.
You fucking cunts who I've been telling
you for the last five fucking years that
Peyton manning is overrated.
I even went off on him last week.
Last week I went off on that guy.
And you can not believe the emails that
I got from people all just fucking,
not only defending Peyton Manning,
but brushing off Tom Brady and
his three super bowl rings as if,
oh, you can plug anybody into that system,
you know? But paint may, who hate Manny,
who paid money? He used to, he threw
for 50 fucking touchdowns during what?
He threw five touchdowns against
the fucking Buccaneers in November.
I said it last week.
Peyton manning is a regular season
statistical juggernaut. All right?
If you want to know who the fuck that
guy is, if you're still confused,
the fuck is there an invasion.
You hear that shit?
That's what happens
out here in fucking la.
So we'd probably just
robbed a convenience store.
They got a little overboard out here,
dude, I'm telling you right now,
if you want to know who Peyton manning is,
you wanna know who that fucking guy is.
Picture this.
If Dan Marino fucked Brett Farve,
their baby would be Peyton
manning. That's who he is. Okay?
And this asshole had only
one one fucking time,
his whole career and all these
analysts on TV, it was ridiculous.
They're all going, you know, I'm
telling you right now, you know,
if he wins here, uh, you're, you're,
you're arguably looking at one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time because
of what? Based on what? Based on
what his regular season stats.
This guy fucking chokes every year in
the fucking playoffs. He's only one once.
He's only one once and everybody's
just fucking talking about and all you
assholes. Who fucking emailed me this
week? Where are your emails now? Huh?
I emailed each one of you,
every one of you fucking back and I
never heard it from you. You know,
maybe he's still fucking stunned.
Maybe he's still fucking confused.
So you know what?
You know what I'm going to do just for
all of you fucking idiots out there who
think that Peyton manning is
the greatest fucking guy ever.
Totally disrespecting Tom Brady.
Tom Brady has to wear,
you know,
he has to wear a fucking welder's
mask at night to go to sleep.
That's how fucking bright his room is
from those three championship rings.
And you guys still disrespect him.
The analysts on TV still disrespect them.
They never talk about the way they talk
about Peyton manning all accounts is
what the fuck you do in January. You
know, nobody talks about Terry Bradshaw.
You guys haven't watched super
bowl 10 it's up on fucking youtube.
Watch that game. Terry Bradshaw,
if you looked at his numbers,
you fucking stat boy pussies.
If you looked at his numbers on paper,
you wouldn't think the guy was
shit. You'd be like, Oh, pick many.
He's like twice as good as this guy.
He's closing in on 50,000 yards.
All Bradshaw has a 25,000 yards.
Yeah, in four fucking rinks.
Superbowl 10 Terry Bradshaw Fades back
to pass and the fourth fucking quarter
gets knocked. Unconscious
gets a concussion. Okay,
and on that play that he got a concussion,
he throws a 50 yard strike to Lynn
Swann for the go ahead. Fucking score.
All right.
That's what the great ones do.
And nobody ever brings up Terry Bradshaw.
You. What the fuck has he ever done by?
Other than when for fucking super bowls.
So just in case you guys are still
confused about your boy Peyton Manning,
I'm going to read you some of his stats,
the stats that fucking count. All right?
Yeah. We go the greatest
quarterback of all time.
I've got a little music for you this week.
All right.
December 30th I'm such an obnoxious ass.
This is Carly Simon,
by the way, singing. Nobody
does it better. You know,
this is what all the analysts have been
singing for the last fucking 10 years of
this guy's career.
December 30th all right.
Kicks ass in the regular season.
Dolphins beat the cults.
2117 overtime wildcard game.
Oh, whatever. Whatever.
It's his first trip to the playoffs.
He'll get better.
2002 colts lose 41 nothing in a playoff
route against the New York jets,
j e t s jets, jets, jets.
This is the greatest
quarterback of all fucking time.
Potentially with one fucking ring.
Everybody tune in and watch and
see how he does against the saints.
That's look how he did.
January 8th,
2004 called slews 24 14 to
the New England patriots.
Greatest swapping quarterback,
potentially a better one fucking ring.
You see his footwork? He's
an unbelievable, okay.
His hand eye coordination.
He's got the pedigree.
January 60 2005 cults
again lose to the Patriots,
20 to three greatest fucking
quarterback of all fucking time.
January 15th,
2006 cults lose to this Steelers,
21 to 18
greatest quarterback of all time and
right around then people start going, oh,
is this another Dan Marino? But no. The
next year he finally fucking shows up.
Finally grows as Dick comes back.
21 points down against the Patriots,
winters for a super bowl, and then I'm
thinking, okay, he's a fucking man now,
right? I'm going to see some
Montana Shit. I'm going to see some,
some fucking Terry.
I'm going to see some time fucking Brady.
What's he doing in the next year?
He loses at home
to the San Diego chargers. All right.
Maybe he had a fucking hangover,
maybe at a fucking hangover. What's
he do in the next year? Wait,
is quarter fucking quarterback ever
loses to the eight and eight chargers at
fucking home? Right?
And you hear this song,
this is what these fucking analyst
has been. Just continue to sing.
He's the new Brett Farve.
Brett Farve can do no wrong throws
against his body over the fucking middle.
And what is Tom Jackson
say? Well, you know,
he's never been afraid to lose the game.
He fucking blew it.
He mushed those vikings purple nuts right
into the fucking ground and it's still
fucking rubbing his god there.
Mississippi Caucus. I'm sick of it.
So here you go.
She goes up against the lowly saints.
They've never won a fucking thing in 40
fucking years of being in the league.
What's going to be the difference,
Peyton? And I'll tell ya,
I got to go with Peyton manning. Oh,
Peyton manning cyst. Peyton manning stat.
Peyton manning lost the fucking
game yesterday. The final drive.
I've got a question for you.
Indianapolis fans.
Does Tom Brady throw a pick six
at the end of the Superbowl?
Does Joe Montana throw a fucking pick six
is Terry Bradshaw.
Does Ben Roethlisberger one of the most
overlooked quarterbacks of all times
sitting in home with fucking two rinks.
Does he know?
He doesn't. All right, so fuck all you
fucking idiots out in Indianapolis.
There you go. How was that? Did you
like that? Right in your fucking ass.
God bless the saints. Everybody. Huh? Do
did they say drew Brees his name? What?
Maybe three times when they finally
figured out he's going to win the game.
Then they're like, oh, by the way, drew
Brees is about to break Tom Brady's,
you know, single fucking Superbowl
record for completions there.
I got it out. I've got a little started
there for a second, but it got it out.
Unbelievable.
Unfucking believable.
You know something.
This is how fucking bad
and Nadeem bad.
How fucking I predicted the IC got Keith
Robinson to fucking apologize to me.
Keith Robinson, classic black dude
doesn't like white people. Hates cops.
Okay. There's no reason
for him to apologize to me.
He actually apologized. He goes,
you know what? You're right.
You were right about this
guy. Uh, I feel vindicated.
Vindication. What a great emotion.
So there you go. There you go.
Congratulations to the New Orleans saints.
Okay?
And I know what it feels like
to fucking have a great team.
And nobody even fucking talks about you.
Do they even bring you guys up for half
a second? Oh, by the way, Big Bang.
The luncheon city, the amount of shit that
you guys have been through down there.
How many Superbowls had
been played in New Orleans?
How many times have you seen people from
other cities come to your town and feel
the joy of winning a championship
and you just sat there, you know,
with your beads and your chicken
foot and you're Voodoo. Go on.
When the fuck is it going to happen for
us? Well, it finally did. Congratulations.
You're totally fucking deserve that.
Your defense was the shit.
Even when the culture receivers,
we're catching balls. I mean,
you guys were hitting them. They
look like they, they'll like many,
many explosions. You will not get them off
their feet. Totally fucking deserve it.
Can't be, could not be happier, could
not be happier. Not only did you know,
I don't know, it feels like to
wait for a fucking championships.
So congratulations to
everyone down in New Orleans.
And I also want to thanks the
saints for fucking proven me right?
Proven me right. There you
go. There you go. All right,
so while you fucking
analysts, hey, then you,
and are you a pas at ESPN in Bristol,
Connecticut. You listen to this shit.
Why don't you go play it to
some of those jerk offs at Upi?
Have on the fucking hair. Who can't
do anything, dude, I'm telling you,
they'll even go on. I'm even watching
a little bit of shit this morning.
This is loosen me. I'm stuttering.
I'm so fucking pissed right now.
They're still not saying, ah Brady.
What's his face paint and blew it.
They keep talking about drop passes.
Ms Field Goes,
get the fuck outta here. Pick six
nail in the coffin. Thanks Peyton.
You know he was going to lose
you see all tanned up. He was,
oh
Jesus Christ. It's going to be
a great week. I feel fantastic.
You know, especially as a fucking
Boston fan, you know what I mean?
I already watched, I watched the Lakers
come in and win another one. You know,
I watched the Yankees win number 27 was
I actually got to sit here and have to
watch the cults when
to and prove me wrong.
That may be Peyton is let's be puberty.
Peyton maybe is,
maybe Peyton is one of the greatest
of all time. Fucking unreal.
I had this one guy this week was sending
me an email saying, you know what Dude,
if uh, if I, you know, if,
if Peyton played for the dolphins,
I don't know what year this guy's talking.
He said they definitely would win at
least one championship and it Brady went
there. You know, it wouldn't
have made a difference. Yeah.
Why would it make a difference?
Brady only is cool under pressure.
How many fucking Superbowls does that
guy have to fucking win on the last drive
to get some respect? I don't get
it. I don't get it. I don't get it.
And what about Ben Roethlisberger who
has twice as many fucking rings as Peyton
Manning?
Okay,
let's look at Peyton Manning's brother
Eli Manning against the Patriots.
Tom Brady, once again drives them down
the field for the fourth fucking time.
For the go ahead score. Huh?
Did Eli get nervous? No,
he didn't drove him right down the
fucking field and did what his big brother
didn't do. Oh, I would love to
hear that awkward phone call today.
Ah,
sorry. I'm sorry to everybody who
doesn't listen. Yeah. You know what?
I'm not sorry. Fuck you. I was
right. I always write. Okay.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
I'm fucking strutting around like a God
damn rooster here. Loving life. Anyways,
let's get down to the podcast here.
Um,
last week I worked in a, I
worked in Irvine, California,
and uh, I worked at the, uh,
the Improv for the first time.
It's just south of Los [inaudible].
And uh,
I gotta tell you something. You
guys ever watch that show, uh,
the real housewives of the Osi? Of
course you don't. Why would you?
All right,
but do you have a woman in your life
who dominates the TV once a fucking week
whenever that show comes on? You know,
you can't help but see it. Right?
I remember watching that show going like,
there's no fucking way.
You know what I mean?
You know, it's a TV show.
They take the extremes of different
areas in the dumber you addicted like the
Jersey shore thing. You sitting
there going, you know what,
there's no fucking way people are that
goddamn stupid. And then what happens?
You go on youtube and you see
bootlegs, bootleg cameras, you know,
shots of the Jersey shore and you're like,
Holy Shit,
there's an element of truth to this.
Now I'm not saying everybody in the Osi
is a 63 year old cougar with their face
yanked back. But uh, uh, wow.
After, uh, after one of my shows,
I hate a group of women coming
up to me who collectively,
I think their age was about 606.
And um,
if you saw it, I don't know these
plastic surgeons to gets sued.
Do these you ever seen Rhianna's Mugshot?
All right.
It's not a mugshot.
You remember the picture after she got
the shit kicked out of her by a Chris
Brown or wherever the fuck his name is.
You remember that?
Just picture that face except
wherever her face was swollen.
Just imagine if it was equally swollen.
On the other side of her face,
like it was a symmetrical beat down.
That's what,
that's what plastic surgery looks like
rather than Evan one swollen up fucking
Aye. You got to and there
and you're like, wow,
what the f did this person get
the shit kicked out of him?
But because they're too, and they're
exactly perfect, Ula and you know,
Michelangelo is dead. You gotta be like,
well, he didn't kick the shit out of her.
This must be plastic surgery.
I'm talking like my eyes,
my eyes were watering when I
looked at their faces and, uh,
they, they, and they all get
like the, the, these, uh, those,
those fucking lips and then not even in
it was a, it was a fucking nightmare.
But anyways, uh, but you know what I mean?
So of course I bring that up on stage and
there was like a talking about plastic
surgery in,
uh,
the Osi in Orange County is like
bringing up Scientology in Hollywood.
It just gets really fucking
quiet and awkward. So anyways,
but I want to thank everybody
who came out to my shows and, um,
actually, you know what? I had
one person come out. Uh, you know,
a lot of people who are in this business
and a lot of people who aren't in this
business,
they try to act like they don't give a
shit about fame and they don't care about
celebrities. Well, I am
not one of those people.
I love famous people and if they
even look in my general direction and
acknowledge me, it actually fills me up
inside. That's how fucking insecure I am,
right? So Thursday night I'm doing
my show down in, uh, down in, uh,
for the fuck was I Irvine, right?
Yeah. Belt. We know you're there.
We're not arguing. Just get to
the fucking point. I'll, right.
So I'm standing there after
the show, whoring myself
out, I'm selling my DV Dvds.
I'm shaking hands and kissing
fucking babies. Right?
And all of a sudden this like famous
people, they just got that thing, man,
I didn't even know who the fuck this was.
This woman comes up and really quickly,
like two seconds just goes, hey, I
thought you were great and shook my hand.
I felt that electricity. And then
she went away. I was like, God damn,
who the fuck was that? I just got done
shaking like fucking a hundred hands,
nothing, nothing. Regular
Hallway Accountant, a plumber,
eight as a college student, she
comes up, she fucking unbelievable.
Felt a connection and then she ran
away. I'm looking at it, I'm like, well,
that looks like a Tonya contain is
how I was standing. And he evidently,
it's tawny [inaudible] and I walked in
there and someone goes, hey, they just,
that was tiny container.
If you don't know who the fuck that is,
she was the best looking video girl
for my money out of all the heavy metal
movies of all fucking time.
The Whitesnake video,
you know the one she danced on the cars.
I didn't like that one.
I like what she danced at the foot of
the bed with that little mini skirt,
barely covering her little a whatnot,
you know,
lifted her fucking leg up like
a fucking show pony, you know?
I know that doesn't mean shit to you
kids nowadays, but this was pre internet,
Internet porn and all that type of stuff.
All you had was Victoria
secret and your imagination.
I guess you could rent
points at that point,
but I was too fucking young and I was
like Eagle in you begin to think of a book
and read. So I never rented one. Okay,
so that's as far down the fucking pussy
rabbit hole I had been as far as video
pussy and a unbelievable
unfucking believable.
So
I don't know,
you guys probably think
that's a lame fucking story,
but I got to tell you something.
When somebody who you used to jerk off
to comes up to your 20 years later and
says, Hey, great job. That's
a special moment. You know,
I had a lot of special moments this
week. I really did. You know what?
I didn't want to beat on my car.
I like saying that I don't
want to beat him my car.
The reality is I have a
Toyota Prius and it has a,
what looks like little
breath mints for tires.
And I didn't feel like driving
it down in the fucking rain.
So I went out and I rented a car and I
rented one of those dodge challengers,
black on black.
All it had was the v six,
just waiting for all the gear heads to get
done. Ah, dude. That's a fucking bitch.
What'd you suck a Dick after you
drove the, it was a v six 3.5 liter.
It's still moved the car. It
was a, I'm telling you man,
even if he get the v six dude,
you're going to feel like fucking
Steve McQueen in that car.
That car is the shit.
I think it's way better than the Mustang.
I rented the Mustang when I
was in, uh, Fort Lauderdale.
So all I have left to
rent is the new Camaro.
I like all of those cars and, but I got
to admit, man, the challenge of man,
that fucking,
you know what it is?
It's the forefront lights for
headlights in the front. I don't even,
I don't even know if one of them does,
you know,
if two of them are just
dummies or they just, you know,
they're like blinker lights or
something like that. I don't know what,
but it just reminded me when I was a
kid that was a sign of status to me,
you had the forehead lights cause I
was always into the caddies. You know,
in the late sixties one they had the Ford,
you know,
the two and two and they
were on top of each other.
And then for some stupid fucking reason
in the 70s they put them side by side
and they just didn't
fucking look right. But, um,
I dunno, I, I would really, uh,
I think I'm going to get one
of those cars at some point.
I've got to find out how much they
are and uh, you know what I mean?
Cause I'm an insecure guy. I mean
that's a perfect car for a guy like me.
You know, look at me. I'm
a winner. Rife of a window.
Dodge challenger 41
nothing. Alright. Anyway,
uh, let's get on with the podcast
here. I got a lot of different uh,
sections to this. I'm hoping you guys are
actually listening to this. If you are,
that means I figured out my new podcast
server that Mark Marin have dubbed the
WTF podcast too. I'm going to
try to have on as a guest, uh,
in the next month. Um,
this is my new server.
It's costing me about 36 bucks a month
and I'm still not charging for my fucking
podcast. This is a little
bit of guilt, so, you know,
I figured you guys can pay me back.
Don't steal my DVD online. All right?
Go on in order the fucking thing. I'm
giving you a podcast every God damn week.
Now, I'm not going to be,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I don't expect anybody in Indianapolis
or re anywhere remotely related to Peyton
manning to buy my DVD.
But the rest of you,
sons of bitches just go on and
pay for the damn thing. Okay?
We spent a lot of money on that.
They gave you a bunch of extras
or come out to one of my shows.
Pay me back that way, okay? And whatever.
If you're in between jobs right now
and you're going through a rough time,
here's some free fucking comedy.
But when you hit it big, remember,
remember who fucking held you up?
Huh?
When you look down in the sand and
there was only one set of footprints.
That was when I carried
you with my podcast.
Look at me getting all biblical.
Why are you getting biblical bill?
I thought you don't believe in that shit.
You know why? Cause I have a confession.
I've got a confession to make to you guys.
You know what I did on Sunday and I
think this is why Peyton manning got his
fucking ass kicked. I actually hope
you're all sitting down at this point.
I actually went to church on Sunday
after all the Shit I talked about
organized religion and all that shit.
I actually went,
I went to church,
I went to fucking church.
And uh,
I don't know why it's one of these
deals is something about I haven't been
drinking. I'm trying to clean up my
act and the last 20 years, you know,
I've just slowly become a complete piece
of shit and I'm really trying to get
back to who the fuck I was. You
know, I used to be a good guy.
I used to not be cynical. I used
to believe in people. I had hope.
I gave to charities, you know, I
was a fucking swell guy, you know,
20 years of being on the road,
drinking who was corrupt club owners
fucking me over at the end of the weekend.
You know, you start to uh, I got
no excuse, whatever, I'm weak,
I'm so whatever. So I was like,
I don't know, I need to, uh,
I need to do something good. So I
was actually, this is how far I went.
I actually considered going to confession
and not even because I believe in the
shit. I just wanted to see what the
priest was going to say. Cause I, I never,
you know, at the risk of
burning some of my new material,
I just never bought into that shit that
like I have to talk to God through you.
You know,
now you're,
you're some sort of voice and you want to
listen to all the fucked up shit I did.
As you look through the fucking screen,
pretending you're not looking at me,
you know,
plus I gotta admit,
I kind of want to see how many our
fathers and hail Mary's I was going to get
considering the last time I went
to confession. It was simple stuff.
Like I beat up my
brother, you know, I, uh,
had impure thoughts about my fucking,
you know,
whatever English teacher or
some stupid shit, you know,
why is that a sin? Doing ice, have
this fucking language teacher.
When I was in middle school,
we didn't have junior high.
It's just fucking girl was so
fucking ridiculously hot. Right?
And she used to wear these dresses with
a slit going right up the fucking side.
You know, it's a little Italian girl. She
was short. So she'd wear the sky high,
fuck me shoes. You know, every once in a
while she'd give us a treat once a week,
you know, she come in with those
fucking things on it. It was really,
it was ridiculous. Um, and
not only that, she was,
she was my French teacher. She's trying
to teach me a different fucking language.
Right.
So one week she comes in,
she literally has a slit
going up both sides.
And she had this habit,
she'd,
she'd write whatever she wanted us
to learn and she would step back.
So she'd have one foot,
like,
I don't know how to explain it.
It's like if you're a wide receiver
and he looking at the quarterback,
checking for the audible,
you got one foot in front of the other.
That's what she's doing.
But she's got a slit on both sides.
So now not only do I see a slip
and the outside of the leg,
I can actually see the inside of
her fucking thigh on the other side.
I am in eighth grade. Okay.
My Dick is that his fucking,
you know,
saluting the troops at that point.
I'm not listening to what the fuck you
saying in English, forget about in French.
And then she ends up calling on me as
I'm sitting there with my little Woodrow
Wilson, right? And she's
like, ah, you know,
fucking whatever the fuck she
said in French. And I had no idea.
And I tried to play it off and then she
got all fucking mad at me because I lied
to her and I didn't have the
emotional maturity be like, really?
Why don't you put some
fucking clothes on sweetheart?
And maybe I'll pay attention to your
fucking language lesson here. All right.
You stand standing here with half
your fucking hoo ha hanging out.
You think I'm looking at chalk on
the board? You asshole. But I didn't,
I just sat there and stared at my
books as she screamed at me. And, uh,
when she told me to go down in the
office, I did, didn't even put up a fight.
Then I missed my bus home and then I
walked home in the rain fucking saying all
this shit that I wish I had the balls
to say, but I didn't. All right.
That was a sad memory. Okay, let's plow
ahead here. So anyways, so I decided,
I'm like, I gotta go, I'm going to
go to fucking church, right? I got,
I got to start doing some
something good in my life,
something positive or whatever. And
for some reason, I don't know why.
I'm going to church because I don't
believe in this shit. I don't,
but um, I don't know. My girlfriend's
mom goes to church every week.
She's a sweetheart. I'm
like, you know, fuck this.
I'm going to go to church
with my girlfriends mom. Huh?
That's a nice thing to do.
Right? Then all my female listeners
just go walk. Did you just do that?
Of course you did. It's a
fucking nice thing to do. So,
you know, and I'm going all out. I haven't
gone to God's house in like 20 years.
So I'm like,
what am I going to do?
Go there with a button down and some
jeans and some shoes. Fuck that.
I broke out the tonight show
with Conan O'brien, suit number,
that shiny one that some of you cunts
bitched about. Some I fault is fucking HD.
And you can see the inside of my nose.
It looked good and real life anyway,
so I put that on.
I'm looking like a fucking million bucks.
So maybe I'm looking a little ray Liotta.
I don't know how I'm looking,
but I'm feeling good, right?
Went to church and I walk in.
What's the first thing I see? I see a
big Jesus nailed on the cross, you know?
And as he looking at me, no,
he's looking down and I'm like,
is he looking down because he's in
pain cause he's slowly dying from this
torturous device or is it part of
the guilt? Oh look, I dude, for you,
hope you appreciated.
You know,
so I'm a guy.
You think thinking negative bill,
don't think negatives is a good
thing. It was a sunny day. You know,
it's been raining out here.
La has never more beautiful
than right after it rains. Wow.
That was the cheesiest
thing I've ever said.
I should just broken into a fucking song
right there. Reminds me of my mother
now.
You'd already as it fucking,
I don't know what beats down all the
smog and you can actually see out to the
ocean. It's fucking awesome. So anyway,
so I sit down into the pew and I got to
admit, it's kind of bringing it back.
Good memories. You know, we
used to go with the family.
I used to go to church every fucking week
from like third grade till I was like
22 I don't think I missed a week.
And I go with my family and then
afterwards we go to fucking Dunkin donuts
stowed and we get some fucking donuts.
I don't know why we get a dozen
donuts and then we go home,
have Sunday breakfast, and then we all
sit around eating donuts. While we did.
It was a good thing though. It was a
family thing. So part of it was like, wow,
this is what I actually felt
better that I was in there.
Right as I was starting to feel better.
First fucking words out of the
priests mouth is a, he goes, hey,
thanks for coming out everybody.
I see a,
I see you all came out here
early to get it out of the way.
She could watch the super bowl.
That's what he says right off
the bat comes with the guilt.
What do you mean get it out of the way?
Fucking game comes on at
three 30 out here. What do
you got? A three o'clock mass.
You asshole. You don't, I'm not getting
it out of the way. How about this? Um,
I made time for it.
You fucking cunt.
I still have to go to the grocery
store and buy the fucking hamburger.
I came here first. It was right out of
his mouth. First thing you fucking says,
all right here.
You guys all came here and only here
one to suffocate him with that fucking
Smocky he was wearing. I was like, no, no,
no, no. You don't try to think fucking
positive. Trying to think positive.
Stop looking at the negative.
Cause there is an element
of this that does feel good.
There's an element of this that
feels right. So I'm still sick
now. You know, and uh,
then all of a sudden they start reading
the stories and here comes the reader.
If you're not Catholic, they always
have a reader and they read a couple of,
a couple of little Jesus did he sing a
couple of songs and then the priest comes
in and he fucking brings it home.
Like the headliner, you know,
reads a little bit of Gospel.
So I don't know what this guy's doing.
If he's reading scripture,
I don't, I don't know. I
don't know the fucking words.
I don't know the technical
words. So anyways, the reader
for this week comes up.
I swear to God, he's like fucking
45 years old and I shit you not,
he's wearing a boy scout shirt,
a fucking boy scout shirt,
and he has facial hair,
a boy scout shirt and facial hair,
and you're in your forties I'm I
the only one who sees sex offender,
you know,
and you would think with the scandal that
has gone through the Catholic church,
they'd be like, hey dude, we
appreciate you coming in here,
but could you take off the fucking boy
scout uniform considering that's another
organization that doesn't exactly have
the greatest tap track record when it
comes to little boys. Right.
But they don't. So I'm sitting
there going, no, no, no,
no. This guy's a good guy.
This guy's a good guy.
He stayed on the path to the right.
Unlike you, Mr Burr, this guy,
he stayed in scouting. All right. If
he diddled somebody at this point,
they would have figured it out.
Maybe he's just a good guy.
He knows how to start a fire without a
match. Let's listen to what he has to say.
All right, and what does he do? He
fucking goes up there and he starts,
this was basically the story.
Jesus is standing on the edge of a
lake as he is. You know what I mean?
James Brown had the cape, Jesus has
the lake. Everybody's got this shtick.
It's fucking show business,
right?
So Jesus is standing by the edge of the
lake and there's a couple of fishermen.
Of course, of course. There was like three
jobs back then. You were fucking black.
Smith of fishermen are a leper. Okay? So
this is one of these fishermen stories,
right? So the fishermen, Simon,
and some other fucking Douche bag is
sitting there cleaning out their nets and
Jesus goes a Romy out Romy out, you
know, 10 feet into the lake and they go,
absolutely wasn't like we weren't fucking
busy over here cleaning up after a
hard day's work. So they roll the dude
out there, he's 10 feet off shore,
and now he's preaching to the
people on the shore from a Robo.
You know, I'm sitting there going,
what a fucking arrogant ass,
but I got to give it up to him.
That's a little show Biz there.
You stand on the beach,
you're just regular.
All of a sudden you're out
there in the water, you know,
all of a sudden it's like
he's got a stage, so whatever.
So now he's out there like the arrogant
ass. He is. He standing up in the boat,
which you're not supposed to do.
You're not supposed to fucking do that.
He just breaking the rule.
Just like when you see a cop
speeding in a fucking cruiser,
not using his directionals.
He's not even on a call.
What kind of fucking example you
set. So anyways, he starts preaching,
he's done preaching.
He then tells these fishermen to
take their nets and they go fishing.
And they were like, wait a minute, son of
God. Not trying to step out of line here.
I know, you know, you came
out of that debt vagina. That
was never fornicated with,
uh, you know, we've been fishing
all day and well, you know,
the risk of sounding crass, sounding
crass, we haven't caught shit.
So Jesus goes,
am I not the son of God?
Did I not just tell you to
bring your fucking nets out
here? And they, hey. Yeah,
sorry man. Will, what was I thinking?
Right. Okay. By the little casino moment.
How about stick your head to that little
fucking hole. Yeah. You weren't laying,
that's why he had the fucking money ready.
Right.
So they grabbed the fucking nets.
I only know that quote because Joe
to Rosa uses that line all the time.
So they grabbed their fucking nuts and
they bring it out to the lake and they go
fishing. And what happens,
not only do they catch fish,
they catch so much fucking fish that
it almost breaks their nets and they're
dragging them back into that.
Jesus is the best shit ever. And
then he looks at him, he goes, today,
you caught fish.
Tomorrow you're going to fish for men.
And then they all walked away,
evidently leaving their fish behind
to follow Jesus to go fish for men.
Can you fuck, I mean, what kind of a
fucking story is that? You're hungry.
You wanted the food. You're going to leave
that to go try to pick up some dudes.
And I'm listening to this with some guy
with a fucking boy scout fucking uniform
on.
I'm not making any of this shit up.
I was waiting for them to start
playing the weather. Girls
Rain in men. I don't understand.
I know it's a metaphor.
You going to go fish for men?
It's fucking Amway.
We got to get somebody else to believe
this shit. What a crock of shit.
You didn't catch shit. And then he
said, hey, put you, netsuite has done,
we got a bunch of up. He said, come on,
let's go tell it to more people so I can
make more fucking money and live rent
free and not pay taxes. So anyways,
um, but I'm still feeling good.
There's something about,
there's something about going to
church though. It's, it's getting me,
get me in my chest is something
that's still feeling good. Oh,
I'm a master at telling story. Okay. I'm
keeping the fucking, the, the, the, the,
the peep,
the blast for many people in this shit.
And I'm also keeping the Jesus freaks.
I'm driving you right to
the fork in the road. What,
is he going to choose Jesus or is he
going to keep trashing organized religion?
Hang in there. Here we go. Getting
into the third act. So then the uh,
the priest there, the headliner, he comes
up, you know, and I'm thinking, all right,
let's, he reads the fucking Gospel and
everything and now I'm waiting for it.
He's going to say, and what does
he do? He pops in a CD. All right?
And all of a sudden we'll listen to
some cardinal is some bishop from the
Vatican doing a guest spot and you know,
and what does the guy said he teach,
he does some quick little bullshit
up front going, praise Gigi.
You praise him for a few benching, knows
your news. Wonderful Day. And we'll,
you know, give days to hear him.
And G. G. G. Oh Geez. Right.
And when he's done saying that Shit,
little five minutes of that shit,
just stroke stroking you with the
Jesus stuff. What does he do? Huh?
Come on people. You haven't seen this
episode before. What's his next move?
What is the move after they bought a you
up and hit you with the guilt and tell
you how thankful you should be for Gigi,
what does he do?
He starts hitting us up for money.
Start setting up sup for money for
some of the poorer churches that aren't
making it.
And we got a quota.
We got a $41,000 quota and
we didn't make it last year.
You know, it goes on and fucking
on. Right? And right then.
Right then my girlfriend's mother
was hilarious. Leans over, she goes,
of course you'd have to come this week
because she knows, I think it's bullshit,
right? Fucking guy in the cub scout
uniform. Now they're asking for money.
So we're laughing. And then the priests,
when they finally, he, you know,
he shuts off the boombox wherever the
fuck. Oh, I know it was a boombox,
but they had it hidden so it seemed holy,
you know,
then he spends the rest of his
homily telling people, you know,
where to fill in their credit card number,
like in an unbelievable detail.
You pick up the envelope in the front.
If you look over there and the left,
if you fill in your credit card,
I'm sure a lot of you don't have
your credit card numbers memorized.
Trying to make little fucking jokes, you
know, and one of the things was, you know,
if you don't want this to be a monthly,
uh, um, deduction on your credit card,
just, you know, check the box.
I love that they're trying to get you
every month and the only way they're not
going to charge your card every month
as if you do something. Then you know,
that hope and all those fucking
old people with hard of,
and they're not going to check
the fucking box in the next month.
I couldn't buy it. Right.
They don't give a fuck.
And then that was it.
And then the mass ended.
But there was something doubt
still, I don't know. It felt good.
You know what it was when I walked
out and they were having their,
their little fucking bake sale and they
were having their raffles and I bought
my girl's mom a ticket to win some
fucking pots and pans and shit. You know,
it felt good because
you around good people.
And that's what I hate about religion
is because the people who show up,
they're good fucking people and
they getting fleeced, you know,
you know it's funny. It's actually,
I gave two bucks if you know,
bought a raffle ticket
for the pots and pans.
And then we walked by another table
and the lady's like, Oh, you know,
this one's only two bucks for this raffle.
And I look what they're raffling off.
It was one of those fucking,
you know,
Virgin Mary pictures with his like
holy blood dripping down her face or
something like that.
And it's like,
I really don't want that hanging
in my apartment. Okay. It's just,
it's creeping me out. I'll take
some pots and pans, you know,
and make a rump roast, have
a little get together. Right.
I'm not going to wash anybody's feet
as they come through the fucking door.
Leave that FGCs. Um, so
anyways, there you go.
Actually went to church and,
uh,
I didn't buy into any of the bullshit that
the fucking guys with the uniforms on,
we're saying,
but there was something that I kind of
felt a little bit nice and evidently
they're having a car wash on Saturday.
I'm going to go by,
I'll go by,
I'll get my fucking car washed.
Why not the car wash in my neighborhood?
They're always protest and that they're
not paying the fucking illegals to wash
the cars. So fuck it. I
don't know. So there you go.
That artist sparks some fucking
discussion. One side's going to say,
I sold out and the other side's gonna
to keep trying to push me towards Jesus.
It's not going to work. I know what
the feeling was when I went in there.
That's that overall natural spirituality
that you're born with, that uh,
organized religion. Okay. I'm
going to give them a bent,
the benefit of the doubt that they started
off with a good, uh, a good purpose,
but they hoard it out.
They whore out that feeling.
But when you do something nice, you
feel good. You know, I felt though,
cause I was there with my girlfriend's
mother and it was a nice thing to do and
I wasn't hung over and I wasn't a Douche
bag the night before I did my shows,
everything was good. I didn't hurt
anybody. You know, I can do that without,
uh,
you know,
you know I can do that and still
have a fucking chicken sandwich on,
on Good Friday. Whatever the fuck
it is when I'm not, you know,
tell me what to eat and when I can
jerk off a fucking jerk off all I want.
He cuts. All right, let's
get to the topics here.
Spend a great fucking podcast. She
got to give it up. Come on man.
It's been a great fucking podcast.
Started off with some music
I got into religion. I'm,
I'm feeling this one and right now
when you know what I'm doing right now,
you think you think I'm fucking
pat myself on the back? I'm not,
I'm actually killing time right now
because I'm trying to get to the fucking,
where the hell is it? The questions
for the week. Podcast. Quick questions.
Click twice. All right,
let's get into this.
Let's get into this as quickly as we
can and then I'm getting Outta here.
Um, all right. Oh, here's
a new one. This is what,
this is one that I like because as you
can tell, I'm really into sports. Um,
I'm into sports the
way I'm not into Jesus.
And is that how I spelled obscure?
O B s c u r e
size.
Spell obscure. It's not,
you spell anything that's
fucking, and that looks weird.
That made sense to my
brain when I wrote that.
You know what's funny is I'm so fucking
stupid. That might even be right.
But now I'm looking at it and it
just looks wrong. You ever do that?
You have actually spell
it right and you're like,
there's no fucking way I got it right.
I'm too stupid and then you look it
up on the Internet. Like Holy Shit,
I got to write and actually got it right.
I wish I could retain that information
because I know God damn well.
The next time I write it, I'm going to
go through the exact same process again.
That happens to me with
the word restaurant. I can
never remember if it's e,
s t a,U r a n t or r e s.
T. A fuck a R. A. U. N. T. I keep
always forget whether you goes,
all right, here we go. Yeah,
that's, that's what I get
for Sansa. Great podcast.
Now it's going to fucking Peter out.
Alright. Obscure movies, bands in books.
If you guys have read a great book,
if you've seen a really cool band and if
you've seen a really cool movie that is
not, you know, I mean don't, don't
fucking recommend Lord of the rings.
Okay? He's check out this
band. You too. You know, they
got a Nigga, they got there,
got a pretty good catalog, you
know, just some shit that is um,
you know, under the radar a little
bit. Here's one foya that uh,
one of my brothers actually recommended.
They recommended the movie,
the conversation that
stars are gene Hackman,
a young Harrison Ford and that
fucking dude who plays Freightos.
I can never remember his name,
but he is the greatest IMD B
I've ever seen in my life. Okay,
go look it up.
You know,
he died tragically young of some
disease is fucking horrible,
but you can't mess with his IMD be he
never did any meet the parents bullshit.
This guy was in the godfather
that he did the conversation.
Then he did the godfather part two,
then he did dog day afternoon,
and then he did the deer hunter
and then he tragically passed away.
It's not even tragic he did it.
There's no reason for him to continue.
Guy Was the shit I was
actually reading up on him. He,
I guess he was one of the reasons why,
you know,
Al Pachino moved down to New York to
become an actor and he was like his best
friend who was a really sad story.
He was engaged to a Meryl Streep,
phenomenal actor. And I don't even
know his name, very tragic, whatever.
But the conversation is a great
movie and I think it's very, uh,
it,
it holds up and it's very,
I don't even know what the
fucking word is of this time,
whatever the word is to say that. All
right, here's something, somebody else,
I'll recommend it. Somebody said, um, he's
a couple of movies recommend you there,
Woody Allen Pictures, um, that
not a lot of people talk about.
One of them is called whatever works.
I'm not going to describe
it because I'll ruin it.
All I'm going to say simply say is it's
worth a watch if you've not already
indulged. Also, have you seen the
flick Allen did a few years ago,
a few years ago called match point?
Definitely not your average woody
Allen picture, but it was really good.
So I'm going to check those out.
And somebody actually
this weekend recommended,
I can't remember.
Sylvester Stallone,
I talked about people getting microchipped
and they were trying to say that's
invested like demolition man was that
the name of it was saying that movie was
so on point as to what the
fuck is going on right now.
And they basically talked about the
phasing out of cash and everybody getting
fucking microchipped and if you fuck
with the deal they turn your chip off.
I think it was called demolition man. Um,
if anybody knows what the name of it is,
please let me know and I'll, I'll, I'll
reconfirm it next week on the podcast. Um,
and here's a book that somebody saying,
um, if you don't have to read Socrates,
this woman from Germany, I thought that
was really cool. Somebody from Germany,
he's actually listening to this,
actually recommended this sang Socrates
is really dry obviously because it was
for fucking 9,000 years
ago. And, um, so they said,
if you want to,
I have a better read for you,
which is based on the great philosophies
of soccer, Socrates, Aristotle,
and Plato,
uh,
is called Sophie's world is the name of
the book and has the same core ideas and
it really takes you to
the edge of your mind.
How great is that to describe a book? It
takes you to the edge of your mind. See,
I love stuff like that.
There's no fucking way.
I'm not going to read that Sophie's world.
It's spelled s o.
P. H. I. E. S. Come on man, start ringing.
Stop being a dumb fuck like me. Come
on everybody. Let's, let's try it.
Let's try it. Try to improve ourselves.
You know, I'm trying, I went to church.
I try not to fucking heckle dude.
You know what's funny when I was there
is I was saying prayers I had not seen
set in like 20 fucking years. And
this is one pray prayer after, uh,
the homily at in Catholic
Church that is like,
it takes a minute or a minute and a
half everyone to say. And it's like,
and it goes on to something like we
believe in one God, the Father Almighty,
the maker of Heaven and earth of all
that is seen and unseen, the Bible by,
I don't even know what the fuck it was,
but it was like one of those
things where like I was just,
I was just reciting it like a fucking
Zombie to the point I was laughing because
I couldn't remember it.
But as people were saying around me,
I was just right on it. You know,
kind of like when there was a song,
if you're really into this band in high
school and you hadn't listened to the
song and 20 years and all of a sudden it
comes out and you just fucking find in
the words like, where the fuck are
these coming from? Cause they, they get,
they had embedded in my head 20 straight
fucking years and not missing mass,
um, or whatever it was.
14 years. All right,
here's his last thing I'm going to read
for this week and then I'm gonna do some
overrated, underrated. Um,
all right, here's some advice.
Somebody was asking me about a
broad over there. Dear Bill, uh,
since you have no idea who I am,
I don't mind writing to you and explaining
my current problem I'm experiencing
with a certain female.
And since you don't know me,
you'll probably be more than honest.
You'll be more honest than the girls I
tell this story to. Okay, here's the deal.
I'm currently chasing this girl that
I've known for a year who for some reason
goes through phases where one
day I'm the greatest thing ever,
and then for the whole next I could die
from cancer and she wouldn't blink an
eye. She also has a tendency to make me
jealous on purpose for no reason at all.
I've confronted her on the issue and her
explanation was that she hates when I
get jealous. All right? Right there dude.
She is standing on top of an old Victorian
House waving the where I'm a cunt
flag. All right. Told you, you
got to get away from this girl.
This is the, you know what
this girl's deal is? She
wants to be in a relationship.
She doesn't want to be in one with you,
but she doesn't want to be alone,
all right?
And in the back of her head,
she knows she's wasting her time by
hanging out with you rather than going out
trying to find Mr, right?
So what she's doing is,
is rather than dealing with that herself,
is she's taking it out on you, you know,
and,
and another thing she's doing is really
sadistic is she knows that you like her
and she's playing you. You
know, just playing with you,
playing with your fucking mind and just
trying to see the shit that she can get
you to do. Fuck her. All right, this, you
know what? You want to fuck that girl.
This is the guy you got to walk
away from her. Walk away from her.
Go hang out with your buddies. If you
don't have any buddies, go get somebody.
Go hang out in a bar and do what
I always say to do. All right,
cause you're wounded right now and you're
going to be in the bar and you can be
feeling now will these girls don't make
me feel the way that each other girl
does.
Fuck that.
You got to beat that feeling down and
you beat it down with alcohol and hitting
on girls. You don't give a shit
about getting the fucking game.
It's going to build up your self esteem.
Now I'm not saying be
mean to these other girls.
Don't take out your heartbreak that
this other fucking chick gave you.
Don't take that out on these other girls
because then you become a con to go out
there and fucking find out
how your personality works.
You know it's going to build up your
self esteem. Next time she sees you,
you got to fucking broad on each arm.
She's going to get competitive.
Next thing you know, your Dick
is in her fucking mouth, okay?
And you finish in their son.
All right,
sorry man. I stood up. I stood up. I
started feeling like a fucking coach.
I want a little big there. Don't finish
unless she says it's okay. All right.
But if you bang are
definitely wear a condom,
you have fucking respect for yourself.
You have respect for your body. All right?
To go out there and talk some shit.
Son,
you had shoulder pads that be fucking
banging on right now and send you out
right through the fucking tunnel
into some meat market. Okay.
Overrated. Underrated for
this week. Uh, overrated.
This guy says children right off
the Bat, I love this guy. He said,
I'm sick and tired of people
doing shit for the children.
We got to do it for the children.
I understand that you need to
look after infants and toddlers,
but I remember being nine, 10 and 11 and
at that age I really didn't give a fuck.
I was too busy trying to hump
some girl behind a garage,
all the while trying not to get caught
by the people who were supposedly looking
after me.
My parents,
half of the little twats just want to
fucking eat cookies and ice cream and play
Xbox three 60 all day.
So I say, fuck the kids.
Help the adults that are struggling
with bills and shit. I love that.
What a fucking great guy.
I love him because he's speaking from
his heart and the right in the end,
it petered out with his ignorance.
Fuck the kids and healthy adults who
are struggling with bills and shit.
I love and shit.
It really just knocks it down by fucking
90 Iq points right down to my level.
All right, I'll go with that one. Exactly.
Why don't we help out the
fucking people without jobs.
And then this is how the his,
his other one underrated, uh,
he says whores and he
spelled it h. O. A. R. S.
I think that's hilarious because isn't
bores spelt with a B, which is a pig,
you know, which is another fucking
derogatory term from a woman.
So he's kind of combined
whores and Boris Horse Hoa Rs.
He said there's nothing
like a good whore Hoa are,
she will make you appreciate a good woman.
I can't tell you how many times I've
looked at a stripper or some country,
little whore and thought to myself,
thank God she goes,
she goes home to some other dumb
fuck wives and girlfriends hate them.
But until you spend the night at
a club full of skanks and horrors,
you can't really appreciate a good woman.
See,
I liked that because it's actually
positive for women. That's right.
That's absolutely right.
I totally agree with you on that one.
And that's the podcast for this week
and I'm not going to go long because I
think this was a fucking great one.
I had a blast on this. Fuck that.
I say a blast. How fucking old am I?
I had a rocking good time. No, I did.
I feel fucking vindicated.
So fucking vindicated.
Peyton manning was exactly who the fuck
I thought he was and they were crowning
him.
King crown and him fucking King.
And I'm not saying that that dude
won't eventually become king,
but you got to do some shit first.
That's all part of that marketing
shit where they're selling.
They're just selling you a like
before they ever do it. You know,
fucking guys come in and lead.
They get a sneaker contract before
they gain a yard. It's bullshit.
When the Superbowl's when I'm in the end,
drive your team down the field,
tie up to score, winning her over in over
time, and then I'll give it up to you.
I'm not that much of a homer where I'm
going to be, I'm going to be a conduit.
You got to fucking do it first before
people say you're the greatest. All right.
I know I repeated myself,
but you know, it's not,
it's not a lot of times in life when I'm
fucking right. And I was right on that.
So congratulations to the saints and a,
all the fans of the saints and all that.
It was fucking awesome to
see that you guys deserve it.
Hope you make a bunch of fucking money
down there and your rebuild the houses
and you give them back to the fucking
people who previously owned them rather
than the consumer want to
build cheesecake. Yeah.
Factories down there. All right. That's
it. I'll talk to you guys next week.
Have a wonderful,
yeah.
Wow.